les appels au vote stratégique à toute
l'organisation du vote par anticipation
les machines politiques roule à plein
régime en cette fin de semaine de
l'action de grâce je veux que tu qu'on
va rejoindre nos stratèges commence à
bien les connaître
robert asselin conseiller politique
justin trudeau à ottawa catherine
loubier porte-parole de la campagne
conservatrice et conseillère de monsieur
un peu pour le québec
les tataw aussi bons jo catherine
loubier jours karl bélanger conseiller
de thomas mulcair il est à nanaimo en
colombie-britannique bonjour karl et
puis finalement dominique valeyre porte
parole de la campagne du bloc québécois
ici à montréal bonjour donc commençons
catherine je commencerai avec vous si on
le vote stratégique on en parle tout le
temps je disais un peu plus tôt est ce
que c'est un avantage ou un risque
énorme pour les machines politiques ne
savait pas à quelle machine on parle
c'est sûr que pour le premier ministre
harper qui est là depuis trois mandats
qui demande un quatrième mandat
il peut avoir un désir de changement qui
qui s'imposent et puis va avoir des
stratégies de vote de vaud stratégique
justement envers lui nous la manière
qu'on prend ce c on pense que les
québécois en général si on parle du
québec sont satisfaits de notre
gouvernement on a vu des taux de
satisfaction dans les sondages publics
de 30 à 37 pour ça traditionnellement
les québécois ont peut-être une certaine
partie voter pour un parti qui allait
surveiller les intérêts du québec à
ottawa donc ce qu'on a essayé de faire
dans notre stratégie c'est de les
convaincre de voter pour le premier
ministre harper
on essaie de leur dire qu'on a les mêmes
valeurs les mêmes priorités on appris
les 24 25 derniers mois écoulés ce
message là il faut lutter contre le vote
stratégique n'est que une votation
étant donné que le premier ministre est
au pouvoir c'est sûr que ont fait face à
cette situation là et et voici ce qu'on
a fait en leur parlant directement de
nos valeurs de nos priorités pour
essayer de ramener le vote chez nous
effectivement al'inverse au parti
libéral vous vous êtes lancé là dedans
le maintenant pour le prochain euro à
l'oeuf pour l'afrique mais je pense que
oui c'est clair je pense depuis le début
son élection sur le changement
et qu'ils incarnent le mieux alors on
pense qu'on est bien positionné pour le
vote stratégique pour le dernier droit
mais on prend rien pour acquis je pense
est important de travailler jusqu'à la
fin puis démontrer aux électeurs qu'on
peut gagner leur confiance jusqu'à la
fin là on va travailler très très fort
mieux quand même juste on voyait dans le
reportage de mylène selon les étudiants
que 5% des votes des gens qui votent
stratégiquement donc robert c'est
suffisant pour un parti comme le parti
libéral
ouais mais je pense que dans cette
élection aussi écouter ses on ne peut
pas le savoir d'avancé mais je pense que
c'est évident catherine je pense vient
de la mettre aussi parce que le promu
nice est là depuis longtemps monsieur a
un peu c'est un gouvernement qui cherche
un quatrième mandat
c'est clair que le vote stratégique je
pense va être plus grands et les
électeurs qui veulent remplacer monsieur
un peu je pense vont se demander d'ici
la fin des élections et même aujourd'hui
parce qu en a qui vont voter qui est en
mesure de remplacer une notion un peu
qui peut battre monsieur un peu et on
pense qu'on est bien positionné encore
une fois sans rien prendre pour acquis
au bloc québécois et au npd dans ce
dernier blitz vers le vote est ce que
c'est un avantage ou un riche comment
ferait avec vous dominique ben en fait
il ya eu un pdf est majoritairement
campagne sur ce sujet là dès le départ
monsieur mon coeur a dit nous on veut
représenter ce changement là sa première
conférence de presse à gatineau
là on voit que de moins en moins de
québécois et de canadiens qui pensent
que le npd va devenir l'alternative
alors effectivement c'est un couteau à
double tranchant pour nous par exemple
ce qui a changé dans cette campagne 6
sec dans une perspective de gouvernement
minoritaire
la possibilité que le québec est donc le
bloc québécois peut savoir la balance du
pouvoir ça va influencer plusieurs
électeurs à mon sens car si on prend le
problème du vote stratégique sous un
autre angle c'est qu'on met dans la
donne soulevé le vote par anticipation
on le voit votre chef vendredi un peu
rompu avec la tradition qui veut que les
chefs vote le jour de l'élection lui il
est allé voter par anticipation le vote
par anticipation ce une façon de lutter
contre justement le vote stratégique
mais c'est surtout une manière
d'encourager le vote
vous savez emmanuel de taux de
participation aux dernières élections
était plutôt faible alors évidemment
démocratie soit s'en sort mieux lorsque
plus
un vote et c'est un peu l'initiative de
monsieur mulcair de faire sortir les
gens on a un long congé de quatre jours
deux jours d'un vote par anticipation ce
qui après une première au canada
alors c'est l'objectif maintenant ceci
dit le vote stratégique en tant que tel
comme vous l'avez dit fait bouger après
5 % des gens et sont déjà qu'ils se
trouvent souvent déçu par le résultat
final parce que il faut avoir une
connaissance profonde des ddd des
comportements électoraux de ses comptes
et pour savoir de quel côté le vent va
tourner on peut aussi se baser sur les
résultats de la dernière élection d'un
pda fait élire 103 députés ont fini
deuxièmes derrière les conservateurs
dans une centaine d'autres alors un
chemin là pour faire pour battre les
consommateurs qui est assez évident mais
nous fondamentalement on croit que les
gens devraient voter pour leurs
convictions pour des plates formes
qu'ils préfèrent pour les chefs qu'il
voit ailleurs l'expérience et le
leadership nécessaire pour remplacer si
tu veux pas revoir un appel contre le
vote stratégique
le vote par anticipation 4l je
commencerai avec vous d'une époque où le
vote par anticipation ça servait à faire
voter par exemple les personnes âgées
les personnes à mobilité réduite donner
la chance de voter aux gens qui tapent
ça maintenant ça fait partie de toute la
stratégie électorale le rôle est votre
vote par anticipation complètement
changé quand les dernières années oui
oui je pense que tu l'a bien dit
emmanuel c'est devenu un choix en fait
les électeurs ont le choix d'aller voter
maintenant ou d'aller voter le 19
octobre
cette fois ci on a une longue période de
vote par anticipation et donc pour les
partis politiques ça veut dire que à
partir du moment où on sait qu on est
dans une période où les gens vont
exercer leur droit de vote il faut être
prêt il faut avoir expliqué si on vient
au vote stratégique aux électeurs voter
pour un changement c'est une chose mais
il faut qu'ils prennent leurs votes très
sérieusement c'est un vote et un choix
important est ce que il veut le premier
ministre maltais au premier ministre eut
d'eau ou est-ce qu'il pense que le
premier ministre harper et celui qui
comportera le moindre risque pour les
quatre cinq six prochaines années à
venir
robert le votre paradis par anticipation
ça fait plusieurs années que participer
au parti libéral on les prépare ses
quatre jours l'autre tactiquement à quoi
il sert par rapport au bout
en fait c'est simple pour nous c'est de
sortir tout le vote
on sait qui est acquis alors le plus de
gens qui vont voter par anticipation
qu'on sait qu'ils sont de notre côté
c'est déjà en banque ces faits la
journée d'élection peut se concentrer
sur les gens qu'on sait qu'on peut aller
chercher des gens plus indécis qu'on va
convaincre la dernière semaine
mais le vote par anticipation est
vraiment important pour nous je vous
dirai ça fait des mois qu'on s'y prépare
on a dans chacun des comtés des banques
de données on sait qui est certaine son
choix là on va s'assurer que tous ces
gens à la sorte en fin de semaine à
munich où ou bloc québécois si c'est
quoi la stratégie si on peut entourant
l'importance du vote par anticipation
par rapport au jour j ben pour nous
comme pour les trois autres partis je
pense que c'est une pratique générale
c'est à le voir si nos équipes sur le
terrain dans les différents comptes et
sont bien rodés s'il ya des
problématiques à corriger parce que bon
vous connaissent un peu la mécanique et
des gens téléphonent et des gens qui
aident les gens les voté il ya des
releveurs de liste faut s'assurer que
ces gens là soient bien coordonné faut
aussi aller faire voter nos travailleurs
d'élections pour qu'il évite de devoir
quitter le 19 pour quelques heures puis
pour nous ça va vers quelque chose de
particulier parce que au québec le
gouvernement du québec a fait adopter en
2012 ou en 2013
la possibilité pour les étudiants de
voter sur les campus choses qui
n'existent pas où il ya un projet pilote
à 7 pour cette élection aussi mais il ya
beaucoup de jeunes dès lors de cette fin
de semaine si qui vont retourner chez
leurs parents qu'ils votent encore dans
la circonscription de leurs parents et
c'est important pour eux d'aller voter
en fin de semaine oui car le vote par
anticipation est ce que la machine est
ce que c'est une façon de tester
justement la machine dans les contes et
les plus serrées effectivement cette
façon de tester la machine de corriger
les problèmes faire sortir le vote
immédiatement permet aussi de se
concentrer sur les électeurs qui
demeurent indécis dans le dernier sprint
de la fin de campagne
évidemment c'est pas une science
parfaite mais il est clair que chaque
partie tente d'identifier ses électeurs
les faire sortir pour pouvoir après ça
libérer leurs machines pour le jour du
scrutin le 19 octobre
catherine est ce que ça a déjà sauvé des
comtés
une bonne mobilisation le jour dans le
vote par anticipation par rapport au
jour j je pense que c'était absolument
important les on a une expérience assez
étayé dans son parti conservateur donc
je dirais que c'est peut-être pas changé
en compte et mais c'est extrêmement
important effectivement et les
ressources sont déployées dans tous les
coins du pays en ce moment à cet effet
là quand je pense que vous brillez
intervenir voyez un bon exemple d'un
comté qui a été sauvée la dernière fois
par le parti libéral le comté de washoe
marc garneau avec concédé le soir de
l'âge de la journée d'élection wayne [ __ ]
mais le vote par anticipation qui
avaient été comptées par la suite avait
permis à monsieur garneau de remporter
son compte et par là par la peau des
dents alors si c'est un exemple de chose
qui peut arriver
et évidemment on verra si ça sera la
même chose cette fois-ci pour le parti
libéral dans l'ouest mais bon mais alors
vous êtes dans le dernier bleach peut
prédire que vous allez peut dormir dans
la prochaine dans la prochaine semaine à
vous cache donc merci d'avoir été avec
nous et surtout bonne forme
merci vous